Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
That'd be the best in the world.
You've seen his posters.
He's the one that does all those crazy posters.
Dope.
Paul Jacobs,
he the one that did Conor McGregor in an MMA glove punching Floyd in the mouth.
Correct.
Here's The New York one with all the dope stuff.
Let me tell you,
here's where kind of McGregor to win.
Here's where Conor Mcgregor,
he can win MMA gloves.
Let's have a boxing match with MFA groups.
I don't think you need to do that if Floyd's ha at boys had some serious
problems in the past with his hands.
Correct.
And he uses those big ass pillow gloves because of it.
And he's been known to not really sit down and he's punching.
Just picks guys apart.
There's no doubt about it.
Floyd is a masterful boxer,
but that's a big transition for him to fighting with small gloves.
He's never been as big as the transition is for Connor to fight with bigger
gloves.
They're going to do boxing.
But I,
I honestly think with how Connor moves,
it's,
don't get me wrong.
Floyd's one of the best of all time,
if not the best,
but it's a lot for them to adapt to.
Connor's big.
He gets fucking hard.
He can go both ways.
We'll see.
I want to see what we get.
All of the work that he's going to have.
It's in.
Oh,
is he the one that did the fucking Joey Diaz and me fucking collar beam has got
them chili with his gum flat
fucking cop,
so he's fine out of his mouth.
Uh,
he's an animal.
Can't really fight.
That's not going to happen.
That fight.
Hey Dude,
it's a lot of fucking money.
Here's the deal.
You made 300,000 by.
Dana had a real good point.
He goes,
Connor's last two paper views where 1.3 million,
1.5 million,
he goes Floyd's was 300,000 and it's a great poison.
Floyd's asking for 500 million or 400 million.
Rather.
He goes,
you're out of your fucking mind.
here's a real deal.
I'll give you 25 million.
I'll give Connor 25 billion and then we'll talk about paper review after you've
written them a thousand from Reebok,
you get 4,000 not a championship fight,
but it's a main event.
Oh Mom,
look at this.
Boom.
Hey Be,
this is why it's getting serious.
Cause Dana addresses it made an offer on national TV.
Floyd was on showtime last night and they go,
is there any boxer that could bring you out of retirement?
He goes,
nope.
The only fight that would get me out of retirement is Conor McGregor is the only
fight I want.
He knows there's so much money in that fight.
Conor McGregor is a God damn fucking happened.
But see,
the thing is that's a fight that would transcend into the total casual person
the same way the Ronda Rousey fights do.
But this soul dump on concrete million though.
This might be like 3 million because he might be like such a freak show,
but he likes three,
four Mil.
I think so Andrea,
what would you say?
Like the biggest paper you fight ever?
Like what was the number number one of all time?
This pack.
Y'All may one is that the biggest of all time,
isn't it?
Before we look at the numbers,
let's guess,
I'm going to say 2.5 is that the biggest ever?
I'm say
I'm saying almost three two point it is for that fight.
It is for Pacquiao.
Mayweather,
yeah,
but I'll,
it's you're,
you're off on the numbers.
What's the number?
I think it's five right?
4.6 mil.
Oh,
Connor and them.
But Damn,
how much might it may work mother making that fight revenue of 400 million.
Oh my Jesus.
So he probably made at least a hundred plus million that didn't,
they say made 150 160 million impact.
Y'all made like 80 or a hundred but him and Connor,
you're getting,
even if you hate Connor,
you're still getting all those MMA fans cause he represents us.
Even though you hate Floyd,
get all those boxes and fans.
Even if you hate Floyd and then the two worlds just go.
Good.
Josh,
do you think that he can,
that they can make it up to that level that you think,
wow,
I want to know.
I want to know why Conor or how Connor isn't concerned.
He'll get knocked out in the first round.
Nothing to lose.
He won't get knocked out in the first shot.
No,
he won't get knocked down the first time.
It doesn't work that way.
As a,
you mean you,
you can protect yourself against even somebody that could cause very high level
and quick and,
and also it doesn't hit that hard.
Con is a lot bigger,
right,
of moves different than a lot of boxers do because he's so used to leg kicks.
He's still used to take downs and he has a different stance.
That alone will be,
we'll take a little bit of time for me where the to adjust to,
but Mayweather has the ability to be in the right place at the right time.
Always.
So deceptive.
It's so deceptive because it doesn't look like he's doing anything special,
but if you watch the way he's moving,
he's never had a position and he's always popping.
You went to that chap and he's still even at (373) 083-0930 nine or it might be
40 lightning fast and take it.
Especially lately though,
he doesn't take advantage of getting out of the way.
He's kind of,
he's winning rounds with the Jab dicon and dodging.
Get out of the way.
Um,
I just don't got it.
I think for common though,
man,
it's a win win for you.
Imagine if Connor lands the left hand.
I'm saying that ain't gonna happen,
man.
Listen,
Connor fought,
I mean rather,
um,
Floyd fought Ricardo Mayorga.
Yeah.
And no,
not recording my orga you're thinking of Madonna,
Madonna.
Mark was my Donna,
right.
Donna connected at the end of one of the rounds.
He connected with a big fucking right man.
And they had had him sit down for a second.
Did he hit 100% but excuse me,
he still,
he's really hot on one shoulder.
You know,
there's really no,
no,
no.
There's a really only once,
but it was the first fight.
The second fight,
Floyd boxes,
Jane Walk.
They will see it here.
See?
And my Donna is,
you know,
murderous puncher just,
and he would throw those crazy chocolate,
Dell style overhand rights.
So he's all over a Floyd here and at the end was one of the rounds.
Amazing.
But listen,
this guy is way smaller than Conor.
Let's think of this.
We're talking about a guy here that's fighting one 47 one 54 Connor,
although he's made it down to one 45 he's physically much larger than this guy.
Connor was walking around.
Am I love that you guys aren't gonna.
He won't put a glove on him and,
and he will not hit him.
And I think floor,
it's going to do whatever want you want to bet,
Brian.
If you want to bet that re lance one,
Sean,
you pay none of them off.
It's a very strange Connor.
He always loses a Conor McGregor is you won't land a shot.
No.
Can You pour me some?
No one.
Not at night.
He's starting to something more on a clean.
She up to me and Joe.
No pouring some more.
Well,
what I do know is a great fighters have,
they haven't done it.
Haven't we a,
I mean,
I know that he may have no doubt,
no doubt any pat Carroll look clumsy.
I know that.
So,
sure.
I'll have one arm.
I know that.
Yeah,
look at this.
He's done it to everybody.
Oh,
see my,
I clipped him there with a left or a right uppercut rather,
but at the end of a,
one of the Hoa dues,
beautiful box factory wants,
hey man,
you don't get to be 49 and now without being fucking sensation now just don't,
he's the best defensive boxer of all time.
Right.
But yeah,
I would say so.
I mean,
he's two years,
Pernell Whitaker loss.
Later on in his career,
he wasn't able to sustain it as long as Mayweather has.
So what may,
where there's been able to do is sustain it better than anybody and also keep
improving.
Right.
Can mean like when he fought Canelo he,
a lot of people thought Canelo was gonna give him a hard time and young Canelo
he's too big for him.
You Fuck Canelo up.
Okay.